what's your favorite essay from the new
book i
john hasness who's a georgetown
university professor
uh he's alive he gave me permission to
do it i would say that one because he
talked about the myth of objective law
so you know the big sticking point for
most people to make the full transition
to anarchism is to have a legal system
and it you know the argument is okay
look at the very base we need to have
a system of law where everyone can come
together and have a base agreement
you can't do this you can do that and
his being a law professor he
demonstrates that the idea of objective
law
is not only uh does not apply in reality
it's
literally impossible even in theory that
whenever you he gives many examples of
like look
whatever this legals case is and these
are you know not
uh these are just basic legal cases like
this person has a sweater this one
doesn't or something like that and
they nail it to each other you are going
to have
whoever is adjudicating this process
they are going to bring their world view
to the judgment inevitably
so there's no reason why everyone has to
be
under the same principle of law and i'll
give you a great example that's a very
they'll be very easy people to solve
you and i are both uh ebay we have an
ebay exchange and you're supposed to
mail it to me
and somehow it gets lost in transition
right so you can very easily imagine one
legal system where you're the seller
it's your responsibility to get to my
hands if you don't get into my hands i
get my money back
another legal system you could say well
i sent it
my hands are clean take it up at the
post office right
both of those scenarios if they're
explicated ahead of time
which one is right which one is just
they both make perfect sense
and there's no reason why you can't
choose
which system of rules will govern your
behavior
and now it gets much trickier when
you're coming to things like
violent crime and murder and things like
that and
that that's a kind of a separate issue
that we can get into later
but in terms of regarding that there has
to be one legal system with one set of
rules
that everyone has to follow is
demonstrably false second
the claim and any literally any lawyer
will tell you
if objective law were possible then you
would know
for a fact how that judge is going to
rule in your case
right if i buy something at the
supermarket
and it's expired milk i'm getting a
refund you know ahead of time
but if this is a legal system you have
not only do you have no idea of the
outcome
you can be certain that the attorney's
fees are going to be exorbitant
and are going this is why how often are
people involved in lawsuits it's
regarded as a nightmare right
because the claim is that equality in
the law
even if you're very very poor you have
to have access to this system
of adjudicating disputes but everyone
knows
uh poor people do not have access to
lawyers and things like this they'll
have access to it if they're the
defendant
they'll have a public defender at least
in the states i'm sure probably the same
thing in britain
but in terms of a lawsuit they do not
have access to this
service which defenders of the of the
government will say
is crucially necessary to everybody how
would that be fixed in an anarchist
society
when you ha everything would be resolved
look at we have it
fixed right now in terms of ebay right
so right now you and i have a dispute
and ebay steps in and either gives me
the refund
or says i'm out of luck chris sent the
sweater and it's
even if i don't get the answer i want i
at least don't have to buy a lawyer
and it's resolved in seconds anarchism
is not utopia
there's still going to be theft there's
still going to be killing
they're still going to be missing
sweaters in the mail the
difference is the resolution of these
problems is going to be much more
efficient
cheaper and much more conducive to peace
as opposed to imposing
judgments that entire portions of the
population
find to be abhorrent that makes sense in
a very binary scenario that's easily
trackable like an ebay
situation but if it was a more complex
one
stuff to do with litigation in business
law business to business transactions
mergers money taxes
what about that surely that's just
equally complicated
sure so it would be the same thing as
going to a practitioner versus going to
a surgeon
right if you're going to have things
that are that technically complicated
you are going to have some kind of
higher level uh court system to resolve
it
but again even in that case it's still
going to be cheaper because there'll be
competition
and different firms that we have that
right now again
private arbitration different private
arbitration would
uh have the capacity to compete in terms
of efficiency now the question becomes
well i don't what if i don't respect the
judgment of this private arbitration
uh that's when you have to you have
things like uh ostracism
uh things like um credit scores
and so on and so forth like having a bad
credit score which are done by
it's not visa or mastercard or you know
american express or britain express i'm
guessing you have
uh which are the ones who are kind of uh
adjudicating the system you have credit
reports right
and they tell both the credit card
company and you what your credit score
is and they're saying
in my opinion these are the odds this
person is reliable in terms of repaying
their debts
and not only is there one there's three
of them so you would have the same sort
of situation where it's like okay
should you deal with you know williamson
co well historically
and it's only going to take one
williamson co agreed
to abide by the judgment of this third
party they refused and that's basically
going to
very factually say it's much riskier
to deal with this guy than it is to deal
with them where even if they don't agree
with the judgment they still
uh even they personally don't agree they
still follow through with the results
it seems like there's a lot more work to
be done on the front end then with that
you might get through the litigation
side more quickly for
deploying the law but coming into it
it's going to be a little bit more
effortful at least in the beginning
because imagine how much all of this
would be to set up and you'd have to
have
some sort of agreed uh rules and
principles between the different
agencies that might be representing
someone so everyone would need to format
their
everything in the same way so there
still needs to be agreed rules and
procedures and regulations over the top
but as as we said earlier like with the
let's go back to the cell phone example
i don't know and you don't know what
happens when i call you
and we have different cell phone
providers and we never need to know
because before those cell prone
providers came to market
they already established procedures on
how to deal with every other cell phone
company
so that their customers don't ever have
to worry about or think about it
so look at it this way in terms of
fashion the problem if anything with
fashion is we have too many choices too
many options
we have you know books and magazines
telling you which to choose
but when it comes to the law you don't
have choice
and it's much more expensive and costly
and the reason
the law is such a concern as opposed to
fashion never being a political issue
is precisely because whatever the
government does it does poorly and and
that's
to put it mildly thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy
peace
you